"Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of Madness" is
finally here, and it's a way different movie than
people were expecting. For one thing, Doctor
Strange doesn’t feel like the main character
here – so who is? Warning: spoilers ahead.
At this point, savvy fans of the MCU know
not to take trailers seriously. Studios
don't want audiences to figure out the
movies in advance, so filling trailers up
with fakeouts has become a common practice.
From editing characters out of scenes to using
dialogue or shots that don't even make it into
the final theatrical cut — the people who market
these movies will do just about anything to lie
to fans about how the actual film takes shape.
The same has once again proven true for Marvel
Studios' latest theatrical release: "Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness." Here's
every time the trailers lied to us.
"We should tell him the truth."
The teaser and official trailer for "Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness"
strongly imply that the events of the movie occur
as a result of Doctor Strange's spell gone wrong
from "Spider-Man: No Way Home," or that Strange
might attempt another spell that shatters the
border between realities in his solo movie.
This proved to be a total misdirect,
since the inciting incident for this film
isn't a Doctor Strange spell of any kind!
Marvel Studios executive Kevin Feige noted at
the film's world premiere, the final episode of
"Loki" provides the singular event that makes the
problems in the multiverse possible. If anything,
Wanda meddles more in the multiverse to
start the movie than Strange himself, as she
desperately searches for a way into a universe
where she can live in peace with her children.
The film's teaser trailer uses lines from the
most recent "Spider-Man" movie to imply that
this film's events result from all the different
Spider-Man characters crashing into Earth-616.
Again, that's not the case. Strange only gets
involved after America Chavez falls right into
his lap with a dead alternate version of himself
and a monster sent by Wanda in hot pursuit.
The first "Doctor Strange" movie distinctly
sets up Karl Mordo as Strange's main adversary
after Dormammu and Kaecilius are defeated.
Mordo, of course, does appear in "Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness" — but not
at all in the way fans expected. Without context,
trailers for the movie certainly make it
seem as if Strange causes irreparable harm
to the main MCU universe, inciting Mordo
to re-emerge and punish his ex-friend
for the so-called desecration of reality.
In the finished movie, Strange only meets Mordo
again after traveling to Earth-838 with America
and seeking out that universe's Sorcerer Supreme:
Mordo, who works with the Illuminati.
The Illuminati explain to Strange that
they killed their universe's version of Strange
after the defeat of Thanos because he was such a
liability for the stability of the multiverse.
While the Illuminati's emergence makes for an
interesting sequence, Strange and America
spend little time with them. Wanda tears the
Illuminati — Charles Xavier and Reed Richards
included — to shreds with relative ease. All in
all, Patrick Stewart's screen time in the movie
is barely longer than the trailers themselves.
"That doesn't seem fair."
Aside from Strange and Wanda,
America Chavez may receive the third-most amount
of screen time of any character by the end of
the film's 126-minute runtime. Audiences may
not have guessed that from trailers, though;
America is largely seen in the background.
Of course, Marvel Studios and Disney likely
had their reasons for holding back this
brand-new character: America's powers,
and the details of how she meets Strange and
Wong in the first place, are spoiler-heavy.
Additionally, this movie is America's initiation
to the MCU. Casual moviegoers catching the trailer
probably don't even recognize the character.
Even so, America makes for a dominating force
in the movie as her powers make her the only known
person across the multiverse capable of shifting
herself between realms. Wanda and Strange both
use the Darkhold to dreamwalk in other universes
through other versions of themselves, but they
need America with them to make a physical leap.
By the film's end, America takes control
of her multiverse-hopping abilities,
and even finds a temporary home at Kamar-Taj
in Earth-616. The character seems like
an important one, who will likely play a
significant role in MCU projects to come.
You wouldn't know it by the trailers, though.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the
Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.